- [Narrator] Donald Trump is
the first former president
to be charged with a crime,
but he isn't the first
former presidential candidate
to be indicted
or for that indictment to
involve a hush-money payment.
Just over 10 years ago,
Democrat John Edwards
stood trial for money
and gifts given to his mistress.
- There's nothing illegal about
giving somebody hush-money
not to talk about it.
If it was done specifically
for the purpose
of promoting your candidacy
for a federal office,
that's where the problem comes in.
- [Narrator] Here's how
the two cases compare
and what we can learn about
the potential strengths
and weaknesses of the one
against Trump from the other.
Let's start with what
happened with John Edwards.
A senator from North Carolina,
he became John Kerry's 2004 running mate
before running in the
2008 presidential primary
against Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton.
He did okay in Iowa but
quickly dropped out.
- It's time for me to step aside
so that history
can blaze its path.
- [Narrator] That year,
tabloid stories surfaced
about him having a child from an affair,
which, after two years of denying,
- Tabloid trash is full of lies,
- [Narrator] He admitted to.
The scandal had everything.
- Could be the biggest
political sex scandal
of our generation.
- I just turned to him
and said, "You're so hot."
- [Journalist] Hundreds of
thousands of dollars given
to him by supporters.
- [Anderson] Private jet
flights and luxury hotel rooms.
- [Journalist] While his wife
was battling terminal cancer.
- [Journalist] John Edwards'
sex tape details revealed.
- It was a huge scandal at the time.
People loved Elizabeth Edwards.
Elizabeth Edwards really helped
John Edwards' reputation mammothly.
So they really sold
themselves as, you know,
a loving, everyday American family.
- [Narrator] Here's what
the Justice Department said
happened during the campaign.
Campaign worker Rielle Hunter,
pregnant with John Edwards' daughter
while his wife, Elizabeth,
was dying of cancer,
was given cash, luxury
hotel stays, apartments,
and rides on private
planes by a wealthy member
of his campaign and a wealthy donor
to be kept out of sight.
These were also given to a close aide,
who falsely claimed to
be the baby's father.
None of this money came
directly through the campaign
or Edwards himself.
Prosecutors argued Edwards
orchestrated this web of money
and that the payments were
made to help his campaign.
A federal grand jury indicted Edwards
on six federal counts of
campaign-finance law violations.
- John Edwards is a lousy human being,
but I think this is a really lousy
and flimsy criminal case.
- [Narrator] Melanie Sloan founded
this government accountability group
and still works in ethics in campaign law.
She followed the Edwards trial closely.
- There was no evidence
that John Edwards
personally gave the money.
Regardless of whether that had happened,
there still would've been
the question about why.
Is the money a campaign donation?
Is it being spent to
advance your candidacy
or is it money being spent to hush this up
for some other reason, I.e.
to protect your family?
- While I do not believe
I did anything illegal
or ever thought I was
doing anything illegal,
I did an awful, awful lot that was wrong.
- [Narrator] New York
prosecutors argue, with Trump,
the reason was clearly
because of the 2016 election.
Trump denies any wrongdoing.
Here's what prosecutors say happened.
In 2016, porn star Stormy
Daniels' lawyer went
to the "National Enquirer,"
yes, that same tabloid,
to sell her story about an
alleged sexual encounter
with Trump from a decade prior.
The CEO of the tabloid's
publisher, David Pecker,
was able to connect her with
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen,
who eventually paid her
$130,000 to keep quiet.
Cohen was later reimbursed by
submitting monthly invoices
for legal services,
which were paid by Trump
through the Trump Organization.
New York prosecutors say
those payment records
were false business records.
- [Melanie] The 34 charges come out
of the same set of facts.
Each time there's an invoice
and each time there's a payment
and each time there's
a bookkeeping record,
that is all the crime of
falsifying the business records
in order to cover up a crime.
- [Narrator] With Edwards' case,
this donor had died and this one was 100
and never testified.
A jury acquitted him on one charge
and deadlocked on another five.
So, the trial ended in a mistrial.
Jurors said there wasn't
enough evidence tying him
to the money.
- We all though that he knew,
but there just was not the
evidence there to prove it.
- It was just a lack of evidence.
- [Narrator] With Trump, prosecutors say
they have evidence that he
was involved in the payments,
besides Trump's name and
signature on the checks,
and that the intent of the payments
was to help his campaign.
Cohen has already pleaded
guilty and served time in jail
for these payments being campaign-related.
And prosecutors say Trump directed Cohen
to delay Daniels' payment
until after the election,
because then, it would not matter
if the story becomes public.
Prosecutors also point
to a similar payment made
to another women, who alleged
she had a sexual encounter
with Trump, Karen McDougal.
They say Pecker and
Cohen worked out a deal
that ultimately paid McDougal
$150,000 for her silence
and that there are audio
recordings of Trump and Cohen
discussing this arrangement.
Testimony from Pecker says
he made the connections
to the two women to ensure
no damaging allegations
would be published before the election
and thereby influence that election.
- The indictment and statement
of facts particularly
do not suggest in any way, shape, or form
that this was ever about
hiding it from his wife.
In fact, they make it very, very clear
that what they wanna do is
hide it during the course
of the presidential election.
- [Narrator] Federal prosecutors,
when charging Cohen on 2019,
declined to indict Trump,
who was still in office.
These charges were filed
in a New York State court.
Experts like Sloan argue that this case
may not even be as strong
as the one against Edwards,
which was in federal court,
even with these connections.
- I don't think this is
a slam dunk by any means.
The fact that it's not
being a federal case,
that it's actually not being done
by the Justice Department
when you have a federal
campaign-finance law
and that it's being
bootstrapped into a state court,
that is unprecedented.
- [Narrator] Trump pleaded
not guilty to all 34 charges.
He denies the alleged sexual encounters.
- This fake case was
brought only to interfere
with the upcoming 2024 election.
And it should be dropped
immediately, immediately.
(crowd applauding)
- [Narrator] He's not likely
to face jail time if convicted
and the trial, if it happens,
isn't expected to move quickly.
The next court date is
in December of 2023.
(light music continues)